once you get past 30 you start to notice
all the new parts of your body that are
trying to kill you your ears and eyes
stop working your knees decide to stop
bending and your reflexes become so slow
you could be jumped by an actual oyster
I'm talking about hair then somewhere in
your 50s or 60s you start to put things
where they don't belong your
grandchildren visit to find you stashed
a jam in the toilet what if aging and
death were simply optional something we
could choose to do if we want wanted to
but something we could also choose to
prolong such a possibility would have
profound implications for Humanity in
time we'd become
Gods but as it happens we don't need to
wait for some far-flung future in which
humans can live forever because some
denisons of planet Earth already can I
should point out that this ability to
defy death exists predominantly within
jellyfish